encuentra las componentes del vector ave
y bueno esencialmente cuando nos
preguntan sobre las componentes del
vector
avn lo que nos están diciendo es que nos
fijemos en el punto inicial
y vayamos al punto final bm pero para
esto nos vamos a fijar en cuanto nos
movemos en dirección x justo aquí es lo
que vamos a poner nuestra componente x
nuestro cambio en x y cuánto nos vamos a
mover en dirección y por lo tanto aquí
tenemos que poner nuestro cambio en
dirección a nuestra componente y es
decir cuánto nos vamos a mover en
dirección x desde el punto hasta el
punto b y cuánto nos vamos a mover en
dirección desde el punto hasta el punto
b así que nuestra primera componente es
el cambio en x delta de x observa que
usamos la letra griega delta para
representar el cambio delta de x es la
componente x o el cambio en x y bueno
nuestra
otra componente va a ser delta de james
o nuestro cambio en la componente bien y
bueno para encontrar estos componentes
qué te parece si en primer lugar nos
fijamos en las coordenadas de este punto
am y en las coordenadas de este punto
ven si observas las coordenadas de este
punto am son bueno su valor en x es
menos 9 menos 9 y su valor en y es
también menos 9 menos 9 menos 9 muy bien
y este punto b tiene como coordenadas a
quien es bueno pues su valor en x es
menos cinco menos cinco y su valor en
yemen es menos dos menos dos así que ya
tenemos las coordenadas del punto a y
del punto b bueno pues con esto que te
parece si nos fijamos en cuánto va a
valer las componentes de este vector y
para eso vamos a empezar pensando en
cuánto va a ser delta de x así que como
siempre te encargo que pases el vídeo e
intente resolverlo
mismo bien pensemos en el cambio en x y
para eso me voy a fijar en qué valor de
x empiezo en el punto inicial estoy
justo aquí en el valor de x igual a
menos 9 y voy desde el valor de x igual
a menos 9 hasta el punto final que toma
el valor de x igual a menos 5 así que
puedo decir que este de aquí esta flecha
de aquí representa mi cambio en x y
bueno podemos decir que delta de x va a
ser igual y ahora observa primero nos
fijamos en el punto final es decir en el
punto al que vamos a llegar y ahí nos
tomamos el valor de x que es menos 5 así
que voy a ir desde x menos 5 ese fue mi
valor final y ahora a esta cantidad le
voy a restar el valor inicial con el que
empecé en x si me fijo en un punto
inicial su valor en x era menos 9 así
que esto le voy a restar menos 9
hay que tener cuidado con los signos así
que si hacemos esto me va a quedar menos
5 más 9 lo cual es exactamente igual que
4 positivo así que delta de equis en
este caso vale 4 positivo y en este caso
tengo un 4 con valor positivo porque el
signo me está diciendo que me estoy
moviendo hacia la derecha que estoy
aumentando en los valores en x y tú lo
puedes ver aquí aumentamos 1 2 3 4
unidades por eso delta de x vale 4 nos
movimos 4 unidades a la derecha y ahora
sí lo puedo poner aquí delta de x vale 4
ok y cuál es nuestro cambio el jem así
que usemos el mismo color verde y para
eso observa lo siguiente empezamos en un
valor de g justo aquí que tenía el valor
de menos 9 nuestra coordenada jett de
nuestro punto inicial es menos 9 y de
aquí subimos
este valor de menos 2 nuestra coordenada
de nuestro punto final es menos 2 así
que este es delta de james pasamos de
igual a menos 9 hasta igual a menos dos
así que cuánto va a ser nuestro delta de
james y lo podemos escribir aquí delta
de y va a ser igual y tomamos el valor
del punto final que es menos 2 ya eso le
vamos a quitar el valor del ebb del
punto final lo cual es menos 9 muy bien
y cuanto es esto bueno lo podemos hacer
aquí esto es lo mismo que menos dos más
nueve lo cual es exactamente igual que 7
positivo así que delta de jeff vale 7 y
ya lo puedo escribir aquí delta de y
vale 7 y lo puedes ver aquí subimos una
dos tres cuatro cinco o seis siete
unidades para llegar al punto final y
bueno una cosa muy interesante que
quiero que veas en este
y es que este vector lo podemos formar
fijándonos en la componente x la
componente i de este vector es decir si
nos fijamos en este vector que
representa la componente x si a esto le
sumamos el vector que representa la
componente y llegamos al vector ave pero
de esto hablaremos con más calma en los
siguientes vídeos